[Music]
hey you guys tomes of terror time and
yes the day has finally arrived i know
i've been promising this since the
beginning of the year like when i did my
tbr video uh that i was finally finally
gonna get around to reviewing kind of
reviewing talking about discussing i'm
not really sure if you can even review
something like this the
cult classic do you want to call it that
uh house of leaves by mark z danieleski
so
my story with this i actually read this
for the first time i believe my friend
liz gave it to me
as a present
back in the early 2000s it was actually
published in 2000 i think it kind of
started out as sort of like a
a bit of like an online story like back
in 1999 and bits of it circulated but
then it was actually published in print
form in 2000 and i believe i ended up
reading it maybe a year or two after
that because uh you know me and my
friend liz we had like a lot of the same
uh
taste in books and we would often loan
each other books and buy each other
books and things like that and she's
like you've got to read this this is
like [ __ ] this is the craziest
weirdest like creepiest most disturbing
thing i've ever read
so i read the book and i was and it
really really made a big impact on me
and i've had it all this time and i kept
meaning to like reread it and i've even
in the interim
uh even though i only read it you know
all the way through like back then i had
like been reading all this kind of
supplementary material and like watching
other videos about it and like other
people talking about it so it's
something that never really left my mind
all of this time and so when i first
started doing the book review channel i
was like man i really have to do a
second reread of that because i
remembered a lot of the things about it
and i remembered like the feeling it
gave me and i remember really enjoying
the whole kind of like form following
function and the whole puzzle aspect of
it because i love that kind of [ __ ] but
you know it's so long and so dense and
so complex that i was sure that i had
missed out on a bunch of stuff and the
thing about this book that's so
fascinating
is that i kind of feel like
if you're kind of willing to engage with
it it's kind of like a shift it shifts
in the same way that the house in the
center of the story
shifts around um because i kind of feel
like everybody will sort of bring their
own thing to it and
even if you reread it and or you read it
in different ways because it can be read
in multiple different ways which i'll
get into in a bit so it's almost kind of
like it's this it's one of the most meta
things that i've ever read seen heard
about or anything like that and the more
times that i read it and the more
supplementary material the more kind of
like uh you know things i read about it
uh the more in awe i am of mark
danieleski's achievement in
just making i mean
just from my point of view being a
writer myself being a graphic designer
myself which you know that's kind of a
big component of this as well and you
know it did take him a long time to
write it took him like 10 years to kind
of put all this together and i totally
believe it because
it seems like every single
detail in here and this is a long ass
book it's like 700 something pages and
there's just zillions of little details
like and everything not just to do with
the narrative you know or the multiple
narratives i should say but also to do
with uh the fonts and the layout
symbols all kind of stuff going on in
here and it's just so
rich that you could literally spend your
entire life
like just going down
little rabbit holes of various things uh
in this book and it just blows my mind
that one guy like created this and i'm
kind of like every time i read this book
every time i think about this book it
always makes me want to do so i don't
want to do something just like it but i
really really like you know it like i
said this is almost kind of like a an
alternate reality game
but
in the like you know this came out it
came out like in the early days of the
internet
and honestly even though i believe it
started its partial life online
um i think that mark danieleski at least
as far as i could determine actually
wrote most of this by hand again that's
kind of like goes along with what
happens in the story
but he wanted to
you know when he finally got a publisher
for this because he kind of like
circulated it among friends and things
like that circulated bits of it on the
internet and it kind of got a lot of
attention when he went to get it
published
he really insisted that it had to be a
print book and he insisted also
that he do
the entire print layout because he had a
very very specific
vision for how he wanted every single
thing to look because as i said
the look of the book really kind of
informs what's going on in the story and
vice versa
so he actually
again as far as i could determine he
actually taught himself quarkxpress was
which what we used to use in the old
days
uh before because i i had to use that
like back in my old graphic design days
too uh i don't even think they make it
anymore but uh i use indesign now like
adobe but uh yeah so he taught himself
to use quarkxpress for the express
purpose of being able to lay this book
out
exactly the way he wanted it because he
really had and like i said just the more
i think about it and the more i go
through here and look at all the like
just the attention to detail it's just
like how the [ __ ] did one person even
come up with this [ __ ] it just blows my
[ __ ] mind like i said i don't really
know how familiar i kind of feel like
everybody was talking about this book
like when it first came out it made like
a massive impact pretty in the horror
community and also in the literary
community because i have to say that
even though a lot of times this is
classified as a horror novel and i would
you know a lot of it is has it has a lot
of horrific elements in it uh
particularly the story that's kind of at
the heart of it
uh you know one of the main narratives
is essentially a haunted house story
kind of uh and a little bit of a cosmic
horror like a lovecraft type of thing
too
but you could also uh place this in
several other different categories uh
you know it's obviously it's called
post-modern fiction deconstructed
fiction uh i've even seen it called a
love story which okay i can get i can
see that sort of it's it doesn't really
fit
i i mean i guess it's literary fiction
but it definitely i don't think you're
you know amiss by saying it's a horror
novel because it definitely does have
a real creepy
kind of uh vibe to it that really
resonated with me i think like the first
time that i read it and actually this
time reading it too it's just kind of
like it creeped me out even more i think
just because i was able to i don't know
i guess like imagine it more than
anything now there are uh a group of
people
you know it's because this is one of
those books that
you either think it's the most brilliant
thing ever
or
you just think it's a bunch of
meaningless pretentious twaddle
which
i you know either way that's fine i'm
not gonna get all up and just like try
and convince them that this is you know
a brilliant piece of literature or
anything like that if you don't
if you don't feel like it's worthwhile
if you just feel like it's a stunt or
it's just kind of like some gimmicky oh
look at what that dude did and he just
like made this crazy looking book with
all his crazy fonts and like you know uh
you know text going in all directions
and all this other kind of stuff just to
be cute then you know then that's your
opinion and if you don't really want to
engage with the book then that's totally
up to you i will
admit
that this book does it does come across
as pretentious but i think that that was
deliberate because i think in some ways
it's also like a satire of academic
criticism there's like i said there's a
lot of different things that you could
kind of bring to this
but i will say that if you are going to
read it then you definitely need to
work at it this is not kind of one of
those books where you can just like lay
down on the beach
and just like breeze through it you
really gotta because there's a million
different like not only is the
formatting very very strange but there's
basically like three or four different
narratives going on uh there's all
different kind of fonts with different
depending on who's writing or who's
talking and uh there's footnotes some of
those footnotes have footnotes uh you
know there's little boxes with like
flipped around text sometimes you have
to rotate the whole book to read it and
stuff like that like i said you could
see that as kind of like you know
gimmicky or a stunt but
honestly i never really thought of it
that way because like i said you know
i'm a writer and i'm also a graphic
designer and i really really like
when
the form of a medium you know in this
case the form of the book
reflects the themes and the story that
are going on in the you know in the text
and i definitely definitely think that
that is the case here because at its
heart
uh house of leaves is essentially a
story
i mean at the heart of the story you
have kind of like a labyrinth
so you know there's a lot of references
to like the minotaur and things like
that so the book actually is literally a
labyrinth in the sense that it has all
of these little byways and things like
that with different footnotes and
different things little stories going on
and they do actually all tie into the
main themes
but on the other hand
you can go down those paths and maybe
some of them are dead ends or you don't
have to you can just kind of like you
know just read the whole thing straight
through and one thing that's interesting
too is i feel like some people that
have read it because i kind of feel like
people that really love this book read
it multiple times because like i said
you know once you kind of go into it and
read it through i usually just read it
right through i don't because i know
some people will go through and read
one narrative
and then go back and read the other one
and stuff because they don't like the
way it kind of like interrupts itself
all the time which i get that uh because
sometimes you know there's these long
diversions and you're just kind of like
okay well let's get back to that other
thing because i forgot what happened but
honestly i the way it's presented i'm
willing to like read it that way but i
think when i reread it i think what i'll
do is i'll just read like one narrative
through and then go back to the
beginning and like read the other one
through and see how and see how that
kind of like changes my perception of it
because as i said this is not just
it and i hesitate to even sit call this
like a book review because this isn't
even i'm not even really reviewing i
love this book but
i understand why i understand why other
people don't uh because like i said it's
not
it's not even like a book it's like a
work of art or like an art installation
and it's definitely something that you
have to actively
engage with if you're just going to look
at it and be like nah
you know what i mean i don't have the
time or the patience or something like
that then it's probably like not for you
and that's totally fine
because you know everybody's different
but
i love this kind of stuff like i said i
love any kind of like arg stuff i love
surrealism i love anything that has to
do with where you have this kind of like
over i like meta textual stuff i like
symbolic stuff i like stuff that
is not spelled out
and i like things that have
multiple interpretations to them which
this book does as well which i'll
probably get into uh toward the end
so as i said i'm not real sure because
this came out in 2000
um and it made a really big splash in
you know the horror community and also
in the literary uh community
and as being kind of this big like oh
the latest thing in post-modernism or
deconstructed novel or you know it was
kind of like really hailed as this big
achievement which like i said i agree
that it is
so this many years on
i don't know i mean there's a lot of uh
discussion about it online still um you
know there i even found like an article
from just like a year or two ago uh but
since it's 21 years old i'm not sure
how much younger people nowadays are
maybe like uh familiar with it because
like i said i've you know i i've read it
like 20 years ago maybe almost 20 years
ago and it's so to me it seems like it's
ubiquitous but maybe some people you
know don't really know what's going on
in it so i'll kind of like talk about
what's going on in it if i can if i can
explain it without sounding like
like crazy and like i said if you
haven't read this book then
the way i'm talking about it might be
completely um like it might not make any
sense because this book it's really hard
to i think you know what's funny it's
like so i'm making this video today i
think last night i had a dream
that i was trying to explain this book
to somebody
so it's like so forgive me if i'm not
super super clear about it because this
has like i said it has multiple
narratives kind of going on at the same
time and it's almost kind of like this
weird like recursive
uh you know story on top of a story on
top of a story it's like it's like meta
meta meta like on top of you know one
thing on top of the other
all right so here we go
now one of the narratives uh concerns
and this is the guy that starts it so
he's this guy named johnny truant
and he is uh apparently a tattoo like he
works at a tattoo shop in la he's not a
tattoo artist
but he kind of cleans up around the
place he makes the needles and all that
other kind of stuff um and he also seems
like he's kind of like a younger guy
he's like a party animal like uh you
know he goes out lots of one-night
stands lots of drinking lots of drugs
stuff like that
so what uh he also um very very early in
the narrative pretty much legit i can't
remember if he says outright but he
pretty much legit says that he's
essentially an unreliable narrator
so that's kind of one thing you're not
entirely sure how much of what he says
in the book is true so you have this guy
now this guy
he has this friend uh and fellow party
animal named lewd
and
lude tells him about this old guy named
zampano
who lived in his apartment building
and he was kind of this lonely old man
and um you know everybody used to kind
of see him he would come out to the
courtyard like the same time every day
and like feed the birds and there are
all these kind of cats like around that
he would take care of and stuff and then
he didn't um come out
one day so everybody see you know
everybody got kind of alarmed so they
called the authorities and the
authorities came and found zampano dead
in there
now interestingly when they found him
dead they took his body away and
underneath where his body was it
appeared that there were these kind of
like could have been maybe claw marks
maybe on the kind of in the floorboards
like underneath his body maybe not we
don't know how long they were there but
he was dead anyway
and uh he didn't leave any uh relatives
or anything like that nobody knew him so
they were just gonna basically throw out
all of his stuff uh that was in the
apartment
but johnny truant goes in there uh
because the authorities are like well
you know we're just going to chuck this
[ __ ] out because nobody wants it and he
doesn't have any relatives and so he
goes in there and he finds this
black trunk
and inside the trunk is
kind of like there's a bunch of stuff in
there but it's mostly what he's
interested in it is this manuscript
called house of leaves
and
so he decides he thinks that it's really
sad that this guy zampano just died with
nobody and he had done all this work on
this clearly because it's just like
stacks of paper and there's like little
cards and like little bits of you know
of detritus and whatever and he's like
oh well i'm gonna take this and see if i
can do something with it because it
seemed a shame just to like throw it all
away
so he takes it and starts going through
it
so basically what we're seeing
is
the bulk of the book which most
which i i kind of feel like is the most
compelling part of the book
is zombono's manuscript zombino's
manuscript zombino had become
obsessed
with a documentary film which may or may
not exist
called the davidson record
now this documentary film
was purportedly
about a photojournalist like kind of a
famous like pulitzer prize-winning
photojournalist named will davidson
and his wife karen and their two kids
chad and daisy
and how they had moved from new york
city to a house on ash tree lane in
virginia
and
they moved there initially because
they're like oh we need to get out of
the city and you know it's it's almost
kind of like the first part of it is
almost kind of like uh you know your
standard like haunted house set up it's
like you know the
husband and wife have been having
problems with one another because he's
always off uh you know taking pictures
like in war-torn parts of the world and
stuff she's maybe cheated on him at
least once maybe more than once uh so
they've there's a lot of distance
between them and so they figure we're
gonna buy this kind of house sort of out
in the country and we're gonna sit on
the porch and drink lemonade he says and
you know kind of reconnect with one
another as a family because uh will is a
or navy as he's called usually is a
photojournalist um he's like so i
decided when we moved into this house
that i was going to make a documentary
about you know just our lives like a
family moving into like trying to get
back
back and connect with one another and
move into the country and we just
thought it would be kind of interesting
so to that end um he sets up a bunch of
cameras around the house
and um you know they kind of start
talking so then they're so so it's
essentially like a found footage uh type
of situation that's going on
uh however not too long after they move
into the house everything seems kind of
normal you know they're other than the
the relationship is a little bit
strained or whatever but you know they
kind of move into this house everything
seems normal until
they go on this trip
and then they come back and when they
come back to the house
they notice that
in their bedroom
there is a door
in their bedroom which uh was not there
before
uh like in what used to be a blank wall
and they open it and there's actually
like a little like a closet type
situation and there's another door at
the other end and that door opens into
their children's room now they're like
now we're pretty sure
that that was not there before
and they're like and it's not like a
closet because there's no racks in there
there's nothing like that so they're
like huh that's weird
and then they go back and they check
video and stuff from earlier like before
they went on the trip and they're like
yeah for sure there was no door in that
wall before
so they're kind of like weirded out by
this whole situation like okay so then
they kind of try to
kind of come to terms with
this kind of stuff
and then over the course of
the documentary it comes to pass
that
will
decides he kind of becomes obsessed with
this closet that popped up out of
nowhere
and he goes and gets the floor plans of
the house
and there is a crawl space on the floor
plans but not the same size as the one
that just kind of popped up and there
were no doors on it or anything like
that
he also notices that if you measure the
outside dimensions of the house and the
inside dimensions of the house the
inside dimensions of the house are a
quarter of an inch bigger than the
outside
and he measures it over and over again
he gets like a friend of his it's an
engineer to come over and be like what
the [ __ ]
and uh they keep measuring and measuring
and they're like okay this is
physically impossible and yet uh they
really can't get that discrepancy to go
away
now as this goes on [ __ ] starts getting
real weird um
at one point
uh there's like in the i believe it's in
the living room wall
in the outside wall like you know it's
it's on the inside of the living room so
it's but it's the exterior wall
uh a door another door pops up
and they open that door and there's a
big ass long hallway and they're like
obviously this cannot exist
because if you go outside the house
that's like the backyard right so you
can't see you can only see it from the
inside you can't see it from the outside
so as this house
begins to
essentially expand and shift
and
you know rooms appear and disappear will
kind of becomes fascinated by this
because like i said he started making a
documentary just like about his family
or whatever moving to this house and
then all of a sudden this crazy [ __ ]
anomaly pops up
and so he begins to document it
and as the story goes on the house
basically starts to
expand to an extent like i said where
you have some like cosmic horror like
love crafty and [ __ ] going on where they
go into a hallway and suddenly there's a
room in there that's like three miles
across and it's like all this like
floors disappear and there's like
nothing in there it's like all the walls
are just kind of like this ash gray
color
and so over time he start he kind of
like gets a bunch of people to
you know friends and like acquaintances
of his to go in there and do like
explorations to an extent where
you know at one point there they go to
the there's this staircase that pops up
like a spiral staircase and it's like
750 feet across and it takes them like a
week to get to the bottom and then but
it shifts around too because like
sometimes you know sometimes it'll take
a week to get to the bottom but then one
time when will is down then he's stuck
down there um he goes up and it's just
like a normal size uh staircase so
essentially
the
so you have this documentary which like
i said is purported to be a real
documentary by zompino who was writing
an academic paper about this documentary
about a house that was bigger on the
inside than it was on the outside
however this paper that was purportedly
written by zampano who was obsessed with
this
documentary basically
johnny truant who's our third kind of
like lair of this who is the one that
discovered zampano's manuscript
just he finds that he doesn't uh think
that this documentary ever existed or
that the people that lived in this house
ever existed
and he so he's not because he's like
he's reading through all of zampano's
like manuscript and it's very funny
because it's just like this very very
scholarly
uh manuscript about this documentary and
it has all these footnotes and stuff and
like some of the footnotes that refer to
actual other
books like other works and other papers
and stuff some of those are real but
some of them are made up and sometimes
johnny like points out like which ones
are not real like this doesn't exist or
you know or or this quote doesn't come
from that from that or something like
that so basically you have three layers
you have a documentary about a house
that's bigger on the inside than it is
on the outside
uh this documentary supposedly does not
exist
but you have this old guy zampano who is
blind by the way and he was 80 when he
died
who has become so obsessed with this
non-existent documentary that he's
written this very very long scholarly
paper about it
full of references and footnotes and
stuff like that to other works that may
or may not exist
and then you have johnny truant
our narrator who's basically telling the
story to us
and then he is also
essentially he starts out like sort of
presenting
zampano's work but then as the story
goes on he starts adding his own
essentially like life story
because sometimes there'll be like
something about
um from zampano's manuscript about the
davidson record and then he'll and then
johnny turnout will put a footnote
and then he'll start like something in
in the davidson record like reminded him
of something that was happening to him
now johnny truant's story is usually
what most people have a problem with
because johnny truett comes across very
much not only an unreliable narrator but
also not all that likeable he comes
across as kind of like i don't want to
say like edge lordy but he comes across
as like this young guy he's like a drug
addict he's always out partying and he's
like and he just constantly
interjects with you know hey we went out
to this club and picked up these two
chicks and so he's always like talking
about like all of his sexual exploits
and all this other kind of stuff and it
comes across as like kind of juvenile
but then as the story goes on and i
think the first time i read this and i
think and i think this a lot of people
have this experience the first time i
read it is that it's like oh man i wish
that dude would like stop interjecting
like all of his sexual exploits into the
story it's like let's just get back to
the expanding house because that is like
the more compelling part of the
narrative
but as the story goes on
johnny's story
begins to intertwine and bounce off of
zompono's manuscript about the davidson
record and sort of resonate in
interesting ways
and it gets to a point where because
it's interesting too because there's all
kind of references
to i mean in zampano's manuscript
there's like a whole chapter that he
writes about the myth the myth of echo
and like narcissus and it's all like all
about it's not only about echo like the
character but it's also about
you know echo like you know talking
about like acoustics and things like
that
because
interestingly it's kind of like
this book is sort of like everything is
reflecting on everything else and so
it's almost kind of like johnny truant's
story even though at first it seems like
it doesn't have anything to do with
what's going on with the house
is actually reflecting back like it's
echoing back and forth with both of the
stories like i said there's also a lot
of references to the labyrinth and to
the minotaur
and
there is actually still some debate over
who or what
the minotaur actually is because as
the
as the davidson record goes on when they
go into the expanding parts of the house
because like the house kind of stays the
way it is but then like all of a sudden
like a door will pop up and then it'll
be like these hallways that go like
miles and miles in every direction and
like huge rooms and huge staircases and
stuff
um when they start exploring it
they start hearing a noise in there
that's like a growling sound and they're
not sure if there's actually a creature
in there or if the growl is just caused
by the house shifting uh like if that's
the noise of it and there's some [ __ ]
that happens later on like i said in a
much more like kind of horror aspect of
the book
is that
some of the people because people do
actually end up dying in the in the
weird parts of the house like the
labyrinthine parts of the house um
either getting sucked into the blackness
or some of them seem to say
stuff like they think there's someone in
there with them or something in there
with them and this is also reflected in
johnny truant's life because even though
like at first he's kind of presenting
zompano's work about the davidson record
it kind of starts to bleed into his own
life in the sense that you know for
example he'll be at work at the tattoo
shop and he goes into the back to get
something and he thinks there's like
some kind of creature
after him but like then when he turns
around he doesn't see anything
so on its surface
this is almost kind of like you know
it's almost kind of like a story about a
guy johnny truant who finds a manuscript
about a documentary but then he
starts to get obsessed with it just like
the old guy that wrote the initial one
is obsessed with it and then it starts
to bleed into his own life and manifest
it into his own life
however this second time that which is
kind of the reading i got from the first
time but the second time that i read it
i'm getting to a point now because like
i said you you read through the whole
thing and like i said it's
it's a frustrating read but ultimately i
think it's a rewarding one but you
really like i said you really have to
pay attention you really have to
engage with it i you know kind of like
react to what it's like telling you
because there's all kind of like [ __ ]
going on like i said there's multiple
interpretations i've seen multiple
interpretations of this and you should
go through and read um there's a bunch
of stuff there's indexes there's all
kind of everything in the end of the
book and i don't even remember if i i
might have just like skimmed this when i
read it the first time uh which is
actually was a mistake because this
actually is very important in the end of
the book in one of the indexes or one of
the supplementary material things at the
end
there's actually a cache of letters
that were supposedly written to johnny
truant by his mother pelafina while she
was in a
mental institution
and reading through those letters
some of which are coded by the way
some of which you actually have to
take the first letter of each word in
the letter because it's it just seems
like gibberish but if you take the first
letter it actually and she does actually
say like in the previous letter that i'm
gonna have to like figure out how to
code the letters because she thought
that
the director the like the employees of
the mental institution were reading her
stuff
um so she asked so some of them were
actually coded and like saying what was
going on so there's all kind of that
going on back there too
so
kind of taken in totem i've seen like a
bunch of different interpretations of
this where i and i don't know i don't
know if i subscribe to this but the more
i've read like uh more things about this
the more sense this makes to me some
theories have it that pelifina johnny
truman's mother
was actually the author
of this whole entire thing
as in
uh there was there was a kid named
johnny truant but that was her son
but she killed him when he was five
because that's kind of a whole thing
like she did actually try to strangle
him when he was five which does come up
in the text
but some theories say that she actually
did kill him and then she was sent to an
asylum and so she made up
him as an adult and so all of this stuff
was her
um i've also heard interpretations that
johnny truant is a real person um and
that his mother and that he made up all
the stuff about zombino and the davidson
record like the the davidson record and
that was all him making all of that up
so none of that zombino or none of that
never existed uh i've seen that too and
that was kind of his way of dealing with
the trauma um i was watching a thing
like night mind did like a four hour
kind of whole thing about this it's an
expo if you want to go check it out did
like a four hour like examination of
this book like it's in three parts
and uh he was making the argument that
that johnny truant
had kind of come up with everything
in the book like everything in the book
was a lie like pretty much everything
that he said zompino didn't exist like
nothing that was in there existed but
that it was just this whole extended
metaphor you know the house never
existed about his mother like his guilt
over his mother being left in this
mental institution and him not being
able to help her and him hating her and
stuff like that and making her into the
minotaur essentially and uh so so the
whole thing becomes a symbol of
his like crumbling sanity his mental
illness his guilt his trauma from
childhood in that reading like nothing
exists
um you know or nothing like you know the
the house of leaves never existed
zampanu never existed it's all in johnny
truant's imagination and it's all his
way of dealing with his relationship
with his mother so i've seen that as
well which seems like a pretty solid
interpretation to me
and then you could even go one more
level up and say that nobody i mean
because this is one of those things like
i said this is like meta meta meta meta
textual you could get into a thing where
obviously this whole thing is fiction
because it's a novel
so
it doesn't really matter like mark
danielewski wrote this
and so everything in it is a lie
and i think that in some ways he's very
deliberately making
a statement about that it's not really a
statement but he's just kind of like
pointing out and that's what i was
saying earlier when um you could totally
read this as like a parody of academia
because of particularly the way the
davidson records stuff is written
where with all these like uh footnotes
and he's always like going into foreign
language like latin and french and
german and everything like that like
almost like he wants to be like super
scholarly on purpose
and uh so so you can read it that way as
well
but
i don't know it's just kind of like like
i said it's almost kind of like you can
say that it's you know an exercise in
post-modernism and exercise in
novel deconstruction it is all those
things like i said if it is pretentious
but
like i said the pretension to me seems
more satirical i didn't get the sense
that mark danielski was like look how
smart i am like in making all these like
references to classical literature and
you know and other things as well but
like making all of these kind of you
know high-minded highfalutin
references
i don't think that he was doing that to
come across as like hey look how smart i
am i think he was making he was like
making
i i think he's like making a joke
essentially i think it's like a
satirical uh kind of thing and it's
almost kind of like a satirical look at
the truth in media it's almost kind of
like a crazy i was listening to one
podcast about this and they said
something interesting they said do we
think because this book came out in 2000
they're like do we think that nowadays
in our quote-unquote post-truth society
is this even all that profound anymore
since the whole point of the book seems
to be pointing out that there's
absolutely no way of determining
what the truth is and somebody even
pointed out too that the metaphor of the
house of leaves which is this ever
expanding house and it just has like
with nothing in there just these black
walls and the floors are like apt to
kind of like fall away into like
bottomless pits and things like that
and uh one guy was pointing out he's
like could it be that the house is a
metaphor for just like there's no way of
ever getting to the bottom of truth or
anything because everyone's
interpretation of stuff is gonna be
different
and i thought that was like a pretty
insightful comment actually um because
but you don't have to read it like in
this overtly like intellectual way you
don't have to read it like that because
the one part of it that's the davidson
record that's about the documentary
those parts are actually really creepy
and are like really it's almost like a
really really scary like found footage
kind of thing because if you can picture
what that would be like like finding a
house that all of a sudden you know has
oh it's like a five mile [ __ ] hallway
and then there's like these big [ __ ]
bottomless pits that don't you know what
i mean and you have to like you know
these big massive staircases and just
like this whole
idea uh that this house just leads into
this kind of like other like endless
dimension
is creepy enough in itself
but as i said it's almost kind of like
it's it's a visual metaphor to like the
whole point of the story where
where you know who says where how do we
get to the bottom of anything because
everything in this
reflects on everything else everything
in this like doesn't exist because
somebody just thought of it and then
just like wrote it down and then there's
just like these
like multiple layers of
of [ __ ] i kind of get to a point where
like i said the more the more i think
about it the more i think that
it's kind of a thing about
about johnny truant's character
and about him
it's it's pretty much about him like i
said which is ironic because when you
first read the book
i kind of feel like a lot of people are
kind of annoyed by his
essentially like interrupting the
narrative or like the manuscript that
he's supposedly like helping to edit uh
is kind of what what it starts as oh i
found this in a trunk and you know i'm
gonna try and put it out there because
it's really interesting and he got
obsessed with it too
but then he starts putting more and more
of himself
into the story and i think at first
you're kind of like
you know why is this dude like
interrupting like this really cool
creepy [ __ ] and everything like that but
as the story goes on i think you realize
that this is actually johnny truant
story like he's just basically making
everything up and it's this multiple
layers of [ __ ] essentially and it's
almost kind of like he's slyly winking
at you and saying that that's what it is
but then
i don't know it's just like like i said
this is a really i don't i feel like i'm
not really getting across like how
[ __ ] weird this book is this is a
weird [ __ ] book okay it's like you
know so if you haven't read it but like
i said if you go into it
don't expect it to be like it's
it's a horror novel it is but
it's not like
honestly it's not really that much like
anything i've ever read before like i
said it's very very post-modern it's
very deconstructed it's very
frustrating it's infuriating it's
pretentious it is all of those things
but
honestly the more
i read through it the more i read about
it the more amazed i am at how
like what a [ __ ] artistic achievement
that this is like how much work went
into this how much like into all the
every single detail of like everything
reflecting back on everything else all
the stuff about like the labyrinth
making
you know the theme of the labyrinth or
the theme you know at the center of the
book and then making everything the
design of the book even kind of going in
with that theme where like i said some
you go through and like some pages have
like you know just one word on the page
that's kind of going down if somebody's
falling and it's like you know or going
down into like a little tunnel that gets
smaller and like these little word
squares get smaller and smaller and it's
just like such a cool
uh it's such a cool experiment
in
you know in art like i said it's not
even really it's a book yeah it's a
story yeah but
it's really kind of like got so much
stuff going on it's really just kind of
like its own thing
and i think that that's why even after
all this time people are still kind of
like fascinated by talking about it and
i've saw like a million different like
forums people come up with a million
different theories about it like i said
you know some of the theories being you
know johnny truman made everything up
some of the theories being like johnny
truett died when he was five and this
was actually all just his mom's uh
imagination
which like i said i'm not sure like a
lot of people seem to not buy that one
but i was kind of like well i don't know
that does actually sound like it could
be kind of because her letters at the
end and those letters actually i don't
know if you guys know but that was
released as their own book uh the
letters that are at the end of this plus
a bunch of other ones were released as
their own book called the whale's tale
letters and um those kind of like put a
lot of insight into maybe
maybe pelophina the mother being the
author of everything as in although
there is one part i did notice this
though in one of her letters because
like i said some of them are coded
in one of them there's a code where she
direct she directly
writes to zampano so some people have
said well maybe zampano did exist but it
was johnny's dad
maybe you know what i mean so maybe
zampano was johnny's father so there's
all kind of like theories about what's
going on in this but that's the cool
thing about it is that
i mean they're just endless
like it's just endless endless rabbit
holes you could go down i just find it
fascinating how
just one person came up with
something this complex and something
where the form of it like the the print
book the way that it's printed uh you
know the way the text layout is like all
the different fonts you know with the
different character like going with the
different characters and stuff um just
ties back into the story so perfectly
and i mean that's just like so so cool
and honestly there's some [ __ ] on here
too which i didn't even notice i saw
this on [ __ ] night mind there's all
these kind of like collages in the front
oh another thing too
so notice how the cover of the book is
like
the cover the outside is smaller than
the inside just like the house so see
i love c i love that kind of like metal
touches like that see i probably
wouldn't even thought of that but i just
think that's cool but uh so there's all
these kind of like collages in here and
one of the collages i can't remember
where it is now but there's one like
collage in here that has like this
little thing in the background that has
all these symbols on it
that are kind of like they teach you
there's i don't remember if it's like
some kind of pilot symbols or a military
like exploration or something and in
some parts of the book those symbols are
used to denote specific footnotes and
see i didn't even like notes like i
noticed that like these little symbols
like you know because sometimes
obviously like footnotes it's like a
number and then like you go and to the
bottom and then there's that number but
some like later on in the book when
you're going to the footnote uh there's
like a little symbol there like a weird
little symbol and then like it'll be the
little symbol where the footnote is and
i was just kind of like i wonder why
that is like i i thought well it must
have some kind of meeting but i didn't
really think about what it was but then
like in one of the collages there's like
a little a little thing that says like
what all the different symbols mean also
there's some [ __ ] in here where there's
one part where one of the exploration
teams has gone into you know the
labyrinthine part of the house of leaves
and um they can't get out because it's
like closed cl basically like close them
in they can't find their way back out
again they're lost because like i said
the house keeps shifting around
so they're like knocking on the walls
and they're knocking like an sos kind of
sound
and
they point out in the book zampano
points out in his academic scholarly
research about the davidson record he
points out that
when davidson will davidson edited the
documentary
he edited edited those scenes so that
they actually spelled they also spelled
out sos so like short short long long or
whatever it is
and the interest so so there's that
level and then if you notice in this
actual book
the paragraphs that are talking about
that are the same they're like short
short short long long long so
it's just it's just layers upon layers
upon layers just like reflecting back
upon one another and it's just like this
huge layer cake of like [ __ ] so like
i said you could go through all
you could spend literally your entire
life
just finding
finding little [ __ ] like that in this
book that'll just kind of like blow your
[ __ ] mind like if you want to like
you don't have to because i know some
people are just kind of like oh my god
that just sounds i just want to read a
book it just sounds like entirely too
much work but see i really like
puzzle [ __ ] like this if you really like
you know puzzle stuff if you like args
or something like that if you're into
args and you haven't read house of
leaves you will probably like really
really dig this because this is
essentially exactly what it is there's a
million million different like little
little paths and little tendrils and
[ __ ] like that you could go down uh that
will lead you in all sorts of
interesting directions and people have
indeed done that and i haven't even like
scratched the surface of all of the
[ __ ] that's going on this like all the
references all the repeated things like
between johnny truman's story and the
davidson record story and the zombino
story and like you know who's this and
that and it's just kind of like
just follow just tracing all the
references alone would probably take a
whole entire lifetime i should note too
that uh you know
as if this wasn't kind of like meta
enough
was that mark danieleski also has a
sister named anne danieleski who is in a
band called poe
and they did um an album
what the hell was the name of it i can't
remember the name of it now but the
album was uh the songs are about
uh you know a lot of the [ __ ] that
happens in this book
and in this book
there is yet another meta thing where
johnny truant the character
goes to see a band
and the band that he goes to see is
playing a song called the five and a
half minute hallway which was one of the
things that was in the davidson record
documentary and is also one of the songs
that danieleski's sister
uh put in her put on her album
and he goes up to them and says hey
what's up with that song the five and a
half minute hallway have you heard of
the davidson record
and they said they'd heard about it and
then they hand him
a
manuscript of this book
inside of this book so it's just kind of
so like i said it's just kind of like
it's like inception but like times a
thousand you know what i mean uh just
all kind of crazy [ __ ] like that and
it's funny because i saw one um i saw
one review on goodreads the only review
was it was a picture of somebody with
the book open in front of their face and
then like behind it looked like their
head exploded
but it's like yeah but if you really
really like that kind of stuff and if
you really want to engage that like i
said this is not a book that you can
just like
read in a weekend or anything like that
it's very very long um you know it's
like look at the you know it's got just
like crazy it's just crazy like
formatting it's just all kind of like
the formatting's all over the place i'm
trying to find like a crazy looking
uh you know some of the kind of crazy
looking [ __ ] some of the pages are like
almost completely blank there's this
kind of stuff here where it's like
inside this block it's like you know has
backwards text uh from this side so it's
like mirror images uh from one another
because like i said there's one of the
big themes and is like reflections
echoes things like that um because one
story is echoing the other story so
it's just there's just so much going on
in this book that like i said you could
spend an entire lifetime there have been
scholarly papers written about this [ __ ]
um it's just it's really something so
like i said it's not the kind of thing
you can just like sit down and read in a
weekend you know pick up your cup of
coffee and be like i'm just going to
have a good time with this no you really
have to
you really got to got to work at it you
really got to put some effort in um i
mean if you want to get something out of
it like i said yes you can just read it
as kind of like a creepy story and
honestly i'm not going to judge you if
you just wanna go through the whole
thing and only read
the parts that are about the davidson
record uh which are all in times new
roman font by the way uh all this stuff
with johnny truant isn't courier font
because he is the courier of the
manuscript that's why they
made it in that font uh and there's you
know all kind of different fonts and
they're like connoting like different
people's stories uh but if you just
wanted to go through and read like the
davidson record that's like really scary
enough on it it's like a really scary
like found footage movie but also like
cosmic horror but i think it's a much
richer experience if you go through and
kind of read all of the other
supplemental material around it because
there's other [ __ ] back there so like i
said there's letters there's
collages there's poems there's all kind
of stuff
that is supplemental to this that will
kind of like tie back into the narrative
last i heard i don't know if this is
going through or not because um
i thought that for a while mark
danielski when this first came out
because like i said this was a massive
massive success
and he was kind of pretty adamant at
first um was like this has to be a print
book because
the way that it's formatted is so is
really so important to the way the
narrative unfolds and you know the the
way that it looks like reflects on
what's going on and the themes in the
story so he didn't really want to do
like an e-book version of it he didn't
really want to do an audio book version
i've seen audiobook versions of it done
but
it's really not the same experience like
i said this isn't so much a book is like
an art installation so you have to like
look at it you know what i mean in its
print form in the form that it was
intended to be looked at to really get
the most out of it i think but
he was pretty adamant too about he's
like i don't think this could ever be
made into a movie which yeah he's i i
could see you could make it into a movie
but it would probably have to be like
[ __ ] nine hours long i did hear that
he was maybe gonna do a series but i
don't think it's actually gonna be based
on this book i think it's also gonna
it's gonna be like a sequel kind of but
i don't know if that's going anywhere i
haven't really heard anything about that
like for the last couple of years so i
don't know if that's ever going to
happen or not i'm not really sure i'd
want to see it because like i said the
cool thing about house of leaves is that
that it's kind of like exists in its
purest form like in its print form and
you know as you guys know i'm a graphic
designer and i've mostly done uh print
work and i really really like i really
am a big fan of like typography and book
layouts and things like that so
so this is kind of like
my
i don't know this is kind of like one of
my favorite things because it's like
it's a great it's a story but it also
like the look of it just feeds right
back into the story and it's like a
circular uh it's kind of like a looping
thing and it's like it's really really
cool and like i said there's just like a
million million little pathways you
could take off it it's very very
interactive in that way and i really
really like that kind of stuff if you're
into i'd recommend it if you're really
into like args and if you're really into
and if you're willing to kind of
go through like because some of it like
like i said some of it you can pretty
safely skim you know what i mean
depending like i said on what you want
to get out of it because there's some
stuff that
doesn't really
you know that's just kind of like there
for like formatting to sort of like
reinforce
uh a thematic element that he's trying
so it doesn't necessarily because you
know there like there's one point where
there's like little sidebars that just
have like lists of names and then
they're just like mirrored and it's like
so i don't think you need to like read
every single one of those because you
know you can see like the point that
he's making and stuff but
i don't know so so just if any of you
guys have read it um you know let me
know
what your theories about it are let me
know
if you thought it was the greatest thing
ever or if you just thought it was like
pretentious piece of crap and it was
just like pointless and why did somebody
waste 10 years of their life writing
this but it's like see i would never
think that because like i said it's to
me it's like a piece of art and
it's every time i go through it i always
have like a new appreciation for it like
just all of the amazing [ __ ]
detail that went into this is just like
[ __ ] blows my mind and one day i you
know i would really like to come up with
something like this
you know of this kind of like because
like i said i love this kind of [ __ ] i
love this kind of like graphic design
book type thing i love book layouts i
love all that kind of stuff so this is
really really right up my alley and i
was really happy to read through it a
second time and i got a lot more out of
it this time i think just because i
picked up a lot of more stuff that was
going on i picked up the association
between the two stories a lot quicker
this time than i did i think the first
time that i read it because i think like
i said but like most people the first
time that i read it i was kind of like i
you know i didn't mind the johnny
torrent character i read
all of his stuff but i was just kind of
like why does he keep like interrupting
like the creepy [ __ ] with the house but
this time i really i understood like the
resonance of one thing bouncing off the
other thing and then got to a point
where oh johnny truant is the one
writing this is actually his story he's
actually the main character you know
even though it doesn't actually seem
like that maybe like the first time you
read through it but yeah if you've read
it uh let me know what you think about
it we'll kind of talk about theories i
could talk about this book all day long
uh but i will try not to
so
that'll do it for this tomes of terror
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye